one rating points at a time this is
gonna be close
if I keep trying to win 19 more
followers away and whoa what's going on
28 more rating points away okay let's
try and play a hedgehog Tom Steenson
asking for Kings Indian attack
I still haven't played the Hedgehog and
it's been a long time so now it's time
for Hedgehog
yeah Hedgehog time okay the point of the
Hedgehog is what pawns on the sixth ring
to control all these squares and then
just wait for the opponent to try and
eat you and then you punish them with
with spikes or other types of weapons so
usually in the hedgehog okay this is a
mean set at night is happy here not to
block the bishop and common move rook e8
rook t yet I used to play before I knew
what I was doing
rook e8 it frees a fate square for maybe
the night maybe the bishop but it's all
about making slow improvements White's
making no improvements so I'm going for
a typical plan of Queen b8 and Bishop
coming to c7 and eventually we want to
play d5 and the Hedgehog will come to
life
what is g3 so d5 requires some
calculation because a lot of things get
traded I think it's okay though it's a
little bit headache-inducing but the
simple thread is e5 Knight moves and
then d4 and if take steak steak steak
steak steaks
it's just a big trade where f3 is kind
of weak in the end and there shouldn't
be any great discoveries with with the
Knights
also the rookie into e8 because eventual
d5 leads to open e file
oh I hung upon I forgot about a six but
eight pawns don't really matter as much
as other things and I think there's
compensation here even though both my
bishops are hanging now both my bishops
are hanging all I can defend with
bishops maybe can defend both bishops
and attack a bishop I blocked this I
unleash my rook and I attack a bishop oh
but before is coming what's going on I
could take on at three as a move let's
take your first and then hopefully I'll
I'll have something it takes takes I'm
not sure what's going on trying to
calculate this I lose stuff I win stuff
it's reasonable
I could take let's take let's take this
way I'll try and take here
[Music]
confusing position I should take on f3
because if I got the Queen to g2 its
checkmates I mean before it's possible
play Knight no that doesn't work I have
to move my queen play this going for
this but there's queen f1 so I could
play Queen a7 probably the best try
there's some funny idea takes takes
takes Bishop a 8 preparing the battery
not sure if that's hopeful or feasible
my Hedgehog has kind of been destroyed a
little bit it's also back rank ideas
what's the plan I just want the Queen to
lead the battery
I want Lou for my king I don't want a
flag I have to do multiple things at
once ok idea doesn't work though 27
maybe there's some merits calculating
this this b7 Queen they're really not
sure
I've rook b8 it's a sad mood it's a
really sad move
I've 16 seconds left - and rook c7 may
be expected
there's some interesting possibilities
though button rook c7 I can take on a -
I just want my queen to come to G - how
difficult can it be I'm controlling be
subtle all my pieces I'm defending from
afar bishops pin to the G to square b7
Queen b1 Forks pawn and King Queen d5
threads mates undo the bishop
and making lifts
pre-move action mmm free Queen Oh free
Brooke free meats
what aqui yeah it was a tricky position
actually opponent took a lot of time and
just didn't find a plan man don't mess
with the hedge holler don't mess with
the Hedgehog you know what I took a
picture of a hedgehog recently in Taiwan
I went to the most like historical
thanks for for joining again I went to
the most historical like Memorial in
Taiwan it's like the Lincoln Memorial of
Taiwan and roaming around like the main
plaza was a hedgehog let me find it
ah here this okay yeah here's a here's a
Hedgehog that I saw in Taiwan full
screen this it was just a hedgehog
walking around just enjoying life don't
mess with a hedgehog it's a dangerous
non-threatening looking creature